hi everyone
i'm michael baldwin i'm a group product
manager in google cloud
focused on ai and industry solutions my
team leads product management across
several of our priority industries
thanks for joining us today the pandemic
has clearly caused a tremendous amount
of rapid change for all of us
today i want to speak about ways that
artificial intelligence has helped
enterprises adapt to those changes
today i'll cover trends that we're
seeing as we work with our customers
the impact on key industries and how ai
can be helpful in these moments of
change
with some specific examples of how
google cloud has helped
as we monitor our own business and
especially as we partner closely with
our customers
there's a number of common themes
related to the pandemic
first a number of industries are seeing
significant shifts in demand
along with increased volatility second
with this uncertainty comes cost
pressures for many businesses
and as these businesses adapt they often
face supply chain uncertainties
in some cases suppliers may be disrupted
by themselves by the pandemic in other
cases they may be struggling to keep up
with spikes in demand
and across the board is becoming much
more difficult to accurately forecast
customer support cases have risen with
channels like call centers getting
overwhelmed
and virtual work has become the new
normal for many of us as people continue
to social distance
and across the board from retail to
banking to media
and beyond we're seeing companies
accelerate their digital transformation
initiatives
and today i'll talk to you about how ai
is helping with these digital
transformations
idc recently said no doubt the pandemic
is impacting how every industry is
conducting business
in some industries ai spend will
actually increase
why is this happening well we think the
benefits of ai
in the industries that we'll talk about
today are going to be amplified by the
pandemic
as we'll discuss in detail in the next
section
so there are six industries that i'll
talk through today retail
in cpg financial services manufacturing
healthcare and life sciences media
entertainment and gaming
in the public sector so first
let's start with retail we're all
consumers of retail in one way or
another
retailers have seen massive shifts in
demand there's overwhelming demand for
food and drug
while specialty and department stores
and non-essentials are experiencing
declining demand there's increased need
for visibility into supply chains
an added need to quickly replenish in
demand items
also it's much harder now to rely on
historical data for demand forecasting
in addition retailers need to be able to
handle an increase in returns from
e-commerce channels
and be able to adapt to using their
stores as distribution centers for uh
fulfillment through buy online and pick
up in-store
we also see an acceleration in digital
first customer journeys
in some cases an abrupt shift from
in-store to online purchasing
that puts a strain on e-commerce
platforms fulfillment operations and
customer service and support
finally during these difficult times
some retailers are closing stores and
are hyper focused on expense reduction
to preserve liquidity
as covet 19 accelerates the
transformation to digital
retailers are looking for more tools to
personalize experiences and sell online
google cloud's recommendations ai
solution can help retailers adapt to the
changing environment
by helping them sell the right product
at the right time
to the right customer as an example of
this one of our customers
digitech galaxis saw a 40 increase in
click-through rate compared to a
previous period
next let's talk about financial services
in banking
digital banking has increased rapidly
from 63
in 2019 to 72 today
when we look at insurance almost 50
percent of insurance agents cited
building new customer relationships
remotely
as the biggest challenge during coven
19. in the payments industry
nearly 80 percent of consumers use
contactless payments today
and finally the financial services
industry as a whole
is facing new and creative types of
fraud
the dollar value of attempted fraudulent
transactions grew 35
in april year over year we've been
working with our customers using our
document ai technology to help
for example with mortgage rates low
there's a surge in mortgage applications
using document ai we've created a bundle
of specialized models
focused on specific document types used
in lending
and are working with lenders to speed up
the processing of paper intensive
mortgage applications
also when the us congress authorized the
paycheck protection program
or ppp earlier this year we made this
same technology
available to help with the processing of
ppp loans
next in manufacturing like in many of
these industries
there's increased cost pressures also
workforce capacity is expected to
decline
due to things like age absenteeism skill
shortage
and economic pressures all accelerated
by covet 19.
the pandemic has brought about an
increased focus on safety and health
mandates
and finally as many of these
manufacturers are supporting the supply
chains of these other industries
they themselves are facing unpredictable
demand cycles
an example of how cloud ai is helping
related to the safety and health
mandates that i mentioned earlier
is how our vision api can be used for
worker safety
the cloud vision api uses ai to detect
objects
emotions text and more to help derive
insights
so for this example it can be used to
detect essential protective gear
including hard hats gloves face masks
and goggles to detect
also it can be used to detect distancing
compliance from other workers in close
environments and to monitor proximity to
machinery and hazardous sites
the healthcare industry has been on the
front lines of many of the pressures and
changes brought about by the pandemic
large health systems saw revenue plummet
in areas like elective care
and elective care has been slowly
resuming after a 10-week hiatus
however smaller hospitals in some cases
are struggling to stay open
providers are beginning to embrace
telehealth with many visits now being
conducted virtually
and this is a trend that we expect to
largely persist
payers have seen a surge in coven 19
claims however these have been offset by
a reduction in overall claims
and pairs are working to adapt their
plans to cover telehealth
the pharma supply chains are stretched
thin and there's a need to transport
time-sensitive
covenanting tests and vaccines around
the world
and finally the industry is moving to
virtual clinical trials
so an example of how cloud ai is helping
here
is using is how in a u.s hospital used
our natural language api
to analyze unstructured data from
patient inquiries across
multiple channels to more accurately
predict and triage covin-19 patients
next there's media entertainment and
gaming if your family is anything like
my family
shelter and place policies have
increased media streaming consumption
and gaming
but content production has been paused
in many cases with sports leagues
physical productions
and major gaming titles experiencing
slow downs in production throughput
because of the slowdown in production
it's more important than ever to
leverage
existing content and find flexible ways
to produce new content
and all of this like in other industries
is placing additional emphasis on cost
efficiency
and flexibility an example of how ai
is helping is the collaboration between
google cloud and fox sports
to enable fox's employees to seamlessly
search video archives
for specific footage using artificial
intelligence
by surfacing relevant videos quickly
media companies are able to activate
library content faster and also as live
sports come back
this capability will allow producers to
more
quickly take library footage and
integrate it with live clips
the public sector at all levels of
government
is working to rapidly modernize the
delivery of essential services
as millions seek support for
unemployment health care payroll and
public health measures
government agencies and academic
institutions just like their
counterparts in the private sector
are moving to digital platforms and
collaboration tools to maintain
operations
and amid this rapid shift there's a
continued focus on data privacy and
security
finally like we talked about in other
areas of the economy
governments and schools are facing cost
pressures and are being asked to operate
with efficiency
and flexibly the state of new jersey's
department of labor worked with google
cloud to deploy an ai powered
virtual chat bot to provide real-time
answers to the 20 most common
unemployment questions
and we'll talk through some more
examples from the public sector later
now let's go into more detail with some
specific examples where google cloud ai
has been partnering closer
closely with our customers i'll talk
about three areas
first contact center ai including
virtual agents
second applying our lending ai solution
to the paycheck protection program
and third how new features in google
meet have been supporting remote work
first let me share a quick overview of
our contact center ai solution
contact center ai helps deliver
exceptional customer service
and increased operational efficiency
using artificial intelligence
it does this in a few ways first with
dialog flow
it automates basic chat and voice
interactions
next with agent assist it makes human
agents more effective
and third with contact center ai
insights it unlocks insights about call
drivers and customer service
interactions
as the pandemic took hold and we saw
that many call centers were becoming
overwhelmed
our cloud ai teams quickly built and
implemented a customized contact
center ai virtual agent to respond to
questions related to coven 19.
the rapid response virtual agent has
been deployed across government and
healthcare
i mentioned the state of new jersey's
department of labor earlier
in addition the state of illinois
department of employment security
also used this solution to address
unemployment inquiries
with more than 2.6 million voice and
chat interactions handled by the virtual
agents so far
in healthcare penn medicine has enabled
24 7 access to covid19
information for concerned citizens using
this capability
next document ai is a solution that
helps organizations unlock
insights from their mountains of
documents using artificial intelligence
it turns unstructured data into
structured data which
means you can now understand it and
utilize it
in the united states the small business
administration's paycheck protection
program
made funding available to help
businesses keep their workforces
employed
during the coven 19 crisis as you might
expect
this led to a massive increase in loan
applications needing to be processed
building on top of our document ai
solution we created the paycheck
protection program parser
to enable lenders to use artificial
intelligence to extract
structured information from loan
documents submitted by applicants
this can save time can be implemented
quickly and securely
and improves the customer experience by
making the loan process more efficient
finally many of us are now familiar with
remote work as the new normal
our customers at google cloud have not
only adopted video for traditional team
meetings
but have also adopted video for new use
cases including virtual all hands
frontline trainings and customer
engagement in fact these are all ways me
and my team at google have used video
just in the past week
and we see our customers doing the same
however when you're having a virtual
meeting there's nothing more distracting
than noise interference
perhaps people chatting in the
background a colleague pounding on their
keyboard as they take notes
or the shuffling of papers the google
meet team has used ai
to limit these distractions by
intelligently filtering out background
noises
in real time and i will play a short
video showing you how this works
[Music]
hey i'm boarding in a minute sorry it's
kind of loud
hey i'm boarding in a minute but let's
dive in real quick
as you can see with artificial
intelligence we can limit these
distractions
and make the meeting much more efficient
as another example of this earlier we
talked about how the healthcare industry
is shifting to telehealth
for example the cambridge health
alliance is an example of a health
system
with over 6 000 staff and 140 000
patients in massachusetts
that uses google meat to support staff
and caregivers
and the solution has become an integral
part of the team's work
they've conducted more than 1200
telemedicine visits today
and their teams are conducting over a
thousand meat sessions per day
for collaboration and that brings us to
the end
so to wrap things up we know this is a
difficult time
the pandemic has forced companies and
governments to evolve at a rapid pace
at google cloud we're here to help you
reach your goals more quickly
and to adapt to your unique needs using
ai and ml
and as you can see from the examples
that we've talked through today
ai isn't a science experiment it's being
used to solve real-world problems
in business and the public sector thanks
for tuning in
and we wish you your family your friends
and colleagues
all the best during these challenging
times
if you're interested in learning more
about any of the solutions that i
discussed today
you can visit cloud.google.com solutions
ai to get in touch and get started
we look forward to hearing from you and
thank you
you